l'équipe réserve c'est le vivier de l'om
le sas entre la formation et le monde
professionnel pour la plupart des jeunes
qui sonna effectifs des cfa 2 cette
année c'est un peu le bac de leur
formation de footballeurs venus des
quatre coins du monde dès leur plus
jeune âge les joueurs ont désormais deux
ans pour signer pro avec le web ou
quitter le club espère cannelle maximum
car elle sur un groupe comme ça samedi à
l'est et à la longueur ce serait super
la réserve a pour objectif cette année
de remonter en cfa malheureusement notre
réserve et en cfa 2 on pensait fin donc
ce matin ses facettes s'échappe de la
supérieure dans cette équipe il y à nico
le croate sénat le togolais confronté à
un problème de licence elle n'a pas joué
de match officiel trophée alexander
jeunes espoirs du gabon qui s'entraîne
depuis peu avec les pros j'ai peur de
mal faire
je rate une passe à un tramway j'irai
j'ai besoin et jordan le fils d'abedi
pelé qui va vivre son tout premier match
avec l'om surpris et j'étais très
content il va concrétiser le rêve de
tous ces minots
ils tiennent le coup on se qualifiera
pour le
réalisée
mallet
légaliser
il faut égaliser faux
je
alors que jordan est parti avec les trop
pour le match contre lorient
l'entraînement se poursuit au centre de
formation
l'équipe réserve a malheureusement perdu
son dernier match contre calvi se base
sur les résultats les résultats ne sont
pas moins direction moyens jusque moyen
sur la chaussure ça ne fait que
commencer
ça évolue très vite avec le avec les
matches qui arrivent donc se chercher ce
qu'il fait saillie rien mon but c'est
footballeur au festin marseille après ça
c'est un peu plus compliqué au manière
l'important c'est de faire découvrir aux
professionnels des footballeurs
professionnels couture dans le temps
l'important est la restaure la sélection
est dur d'autant que pour certains le
temps joue en leur défaveur
olivier originaire de la région est
absent des terrains depuis un an et demi
il a subi une rupture des ligaments
croisés du genou
le cauchemar de tout footballeur
patiemment il s'est remis de sa blessure
mais la veille de reprendre les matches
une nouvelle rupture des ligaments
devait prolonger cette absence
chirurgien qui m'a opéré les deux fois
ici très bien occupé de moi aujourd'hui
j'allais la voir pour avoir un peu son
accord pour essayer de reprendre le plus
rapidement possible on a donné l'accord
de reprendre ce qui est pivot les appuis
toucher du ballon tout ça pour lycéens
moi j'espère sur le ballon même avant
j'espère je sais pas si vous pouvez
comprendre parce que ça peut représenter
pour le jeune joueur l1 demi d'absence
du terrain quand il était titulaire et
tout donc on a fait une étude
statistique sur tous les centres de
formation en gros presque tous les
centres de croiser par donc on fait tout
ce qu'on peut mais
c'est tout un travail à la nature du
terrain il ya conditions de fatigue et
tout un tas de paramètres entrent en jeu
pourquoi le joueur n'a mené 5-3 et
bombay sa seule réponse en serez content
stagiaires deuxième année il lui reste
peu de temps pour récupérer et espérer
signer un contrat pro d'ici la fin de la
saison je vois le bout du tunnel espère
reprendre
j'y suis un mois et pour finir au moins
et six derniers mois bien comme il faut
pour pouvoir respirer revenir à mon
niveau déjà me soigner mon genou fin que
ça aille bien pour essayer d'atteindre
groupe pro alors on sait jamais ce qui
peut se passer
ce soir à la bastide
tous les jeunes sont rivés devant la
télé pour voir leurs copains à jordan
sur le banc des pros une victoire contre
lorient serait décisive pour que l'om se
maintiennent dans le peloton de tête du
championnat
garder les gars ce qui vous attend vous
persévérez même s'il n'est que
remplaçant participer à un match
officiel avec le groupe pro pour la
première fois de sa vie est un immense
privilège mais faire son entrée sur le
terrain c'est encore autre chose
là il ya une exigence de performance
immédiate et il faut très vite montré
quand on intègre l'équipe eu une qu'on a
le niveau pour y jouer quoi là parce que
personne ne fera de cadeau un jeune
sorti du centre de formation
contre toute attente en deuxième période
jordan fait son entrée sur le terrain
peut-être connaître
donc les bons évidemment le premier
match et les premières minutes sont
hyper importante parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'attentes et que de suite il faut
monter son niveau de jeu aux minima aux
joueurs que vous remplacez qui est un
joueur confirmé vous pour votre premier
match scharrach de faire au moins aussi
bien avec un score de 1-0 pour lorient
l'om s'achemine vers une décevante
défaite huit minutes après son entrée
sur le terrain sur une passe de taiwo
koné récupère un ballon difficile sur le
côté gauche il s'arrache passe le
défenseur lève la tête et centre le
jeune jordan chagny et du plat du pied
inscrit son premier but avec lui
les dieux du football ce soir là avait
décidé d'offrir le plus beau cadeau
qu'ils soient joueurs dont c'est le
premier match de ligue 1
le minot redonne espoir à toute l'équipe
et l'om arrachent une victoire cruciale
en fin de match
av
bravo à lui
c'est une journée spéciale pour moi ma
famille mon frère et le centre de
formation de l'olympique de marseille
n'aura il est où le ver millions de
l'adverbe ideo pro non il est où le sort
des tu prends la tête ce soir à la
bastide en fête noël
pour l'occasion les anciens de
l'internât sont venus participer à la
fête
ici c'est ma maison c'est ma première
maison je suis parti à l'âge de 15 ans
de las martinés pour venir ici et c'est
ici que j'ai attiré on va dire et c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment ma famille à
marseille le centre de formation avec
toutes les personnes qui sont là bon
après y'a un mec qui n'est pas la série
comptoir ce soit qui ait vraiment malade
qui très malade sans oublier salim akki
un peu notre honneur notre maman essayer
c'est vrai c'est
on peut pas oublier le sens et c'est
notre vie à marcel parent pour vous tous
je vous souhaite de faire une très bonne
carrière qui salue la chance pouvoir
atteindre le haut niveau et pour ça ça
passe par beaucoup de sacrifices vous
avez plusieurs exemples comme gary comme
baho et le combinard aussi jordan qui a
eu la chance de marquer un but il a
dédicacé pour le centre parce que j'ai
ici une histoire et j'espère que
l'histoire va coacher à avancer grâce à
vous et aux futurs internes qui viendra
laissez moi je suis parti du centre et
on a que je connais un gars que je
connais pas trop bien parce qu'il va
leur arriver cette année n'en va pas ça
vous devez montrer ce que vous savez
faire
voilà déjà le passé une bonne soirée et
à l'année prochaine j'espère que les
championnats je regarderai plus un bal
en les regardant renvoie pas ce cas on
va fait assez de réflexion quand on
gagne pas alors vous perdez est arrivé
c'est moi qui perd aussi alors comme je
n'aime pas perdre
j'espère que vous n'avez pu vous perdrez
plus et bon appétit
voilà des jeunes
dire scénarisé pour son premier match en
liga avec l'om c'est quelque chose de
normal ça se passe bien pour l'instant
non content
oui confie olivier échauffement non je
n'étais pas sûr qu'on est con quand il
m'a appelé pour venir me changer tout
j'étais surpris parce que la vie ben
arfa côté ben arfa c'est pas la face b
narquois que du bonheur il m'a fait
confiance en me touche comme moi je
remercie beaucoup
coach je peux vous dire que le foot ça
va très très vite
comme la semaine dernière j'étais en 19
ans on a perdu 3 0 hélas au bout d'eux
mêmes par semaine je suis chez eux avec
les pros et
on gagne un gain je marque un but
magnifique que c'est une semaine de
folie
le jeune qui va sortir qui va passer de
ceux de cette formation au niveau
professionnel qui va jouer son premier
match ça va bien se passer
ok je suis tu
bon c'est comme ça à marseille ils vont
te dire c'est super le minot il est trop
fort
oui mais si toi à un moment donné tu le
penses tu le crois ce que les gens te
disent tiens bon parce que à un moment
donné tu vas te dire oui je suis moi le
meilleur média 20 ans et quand ça veut
pas tu peux pas dire je suis maire c'est
quelque chose d'extraordinaire d'être
footballeur la chance de faire d'une
passion son métier il ya peu de
personnes qui peuvent prétendre à ça
donc il faut qu'ils se rendent compte au
quotidien que ce sont des privilégiés
mais par rapport à tout l'entourage la
famille les conseillers les agents
forcément ça complique un petit peu ce
qui se passe dans la tête de ces jeunes
quand on voit des gamins qui déjà à 18
ans penser gagner tant les vins le
gagner tant parce qu'aujourd'hui on a
des gamins cas à 16 ans qui viennent me
voir qui arrive avec un agent dans le
bureau qui vous parle de deux contrats
tant par mois et là vous avez perdu le
joueur vous avez perdu tout ce qui tous
les repères qui font que et vous savez
dès le départ que sauf un miracle ça va
être un échec
ça va être un échec parce que tout ce
qui fait tout est construit sur le sur
l'aspect financier économique et pas sur
l'aspect sportif ça c'est dramatique
je m'appelle trop mais non c'est le
monde entier qui m'appellent pour tout
joueur de foot
le premier match officiel avec les pros
reste un souvenir gravé à tout jamais
garry bocaly en sait quelque chose
il a fait partie de cette génération de
minots qui en 2006 a su créer l'exploit
avec l'équipe réserve
j'ai la chance de pouvoir faire mon
premier match au parc des princes en
plus ce clasico et m'a toujours dit que
le foot aller très vite mais là c'était
vraiment quelque chose de magnifique
regard envahi par des supporters chauds
bouillants
non nous ne sommes pas au lendemain d'un
exploit de l'om en coupe d'europe mais
d'un match nul 0-0 à paris enfin c'est
bien connu à marseille on a le sens de
la démo l'attendions tallec pas vraiment
qu'elle n'a pas l'habitude nous les
jeunes
de la réserve qui nous tient en échec 0
0 chez nous ça veut dire quoi ça les
gens qui ont pillé les cette année la
pâque diouf alors président de l'om
menace la ligue de ne pas envoyer ses
joueurs à paris pour la rencontre psg om
le match est placé sous haute tension et
l'om jugent insuffisantes les conditions
de sécurité pour ses supporters je ne
souviens pas peu m'appelle ça doit être
23h de trois jours avant il me dit je
suis dans la merde parce que lui
l'objectif ne pas poser pas c'était de
refuser d'aller jouer il m'a dit je
pense que je vais être obligé parce que
la ligue mettait une pression forte et
je suis être obligé de faire marche
arrière et puis on est en train de
parler et puis j écoute tu sais il ya un
truc à faire très simple on monte avec
la cfa et là c'est chez lui ça at-il
fait il m'a dit j'ai pas pensé
voilà tu as raison c'est ça
alors qu'ils n'ont jamais disputé de
match officiel en ligue 1 l'équipe des
minots se retrouve propulsé au parc des
princes face au psg
le souci c'est qu'on voulait pas prendre
un carton parce qu'on se disait si on
prend un carton pour être la risée de la
france et elle est partie comme ça avec
le trouillomètre à zéro
ça a commencé à se tétaniser quand on
est arrivés au parc c'est vrai que
l'événement commencé par exemple
dimensions pour eux
je ne
quand tu as un terrain que tu vois les
mecs passé comme pauleta des mecs que
tôt ou tard pour habitude de voir et
élégant il que l'espace de deux jours
vraiment ce type en six parties ont eu
le coup d'envoi pendant un quart d'heure
on a compris que pour épurer nous
arriver
tu t'es pas là
aucun rêve pour eux pour mai
devant d'avoir réussi notre pari je peux
vous dire que ça a été ça c'est vraiment
un moment marquant du club qui restera
dans les annales parce que c'est assez
exceptionnel
quatre ans plus tard l'équipe réserve
porte le lourd héritage de ces épisodes
de légende qui ont marqué le club
c'est sous un soleil glacial qu'elle
entame sa deuxième partie de saison
alors que l'équipe première est qualifié
pour le quart de finale de coupe de la
ligue et remonte doucement au classement
l'équipe réserve vacille aucune victoire
sur les trois premiers matches de cette
nouvelle année parce qu'on a mis au
niveau d'équipés cfa 2 on a un peu du
mal à enchaîner les victoires et cette
année simple des chocolats on arrive à
faire un très bon mois et une semaine
d'après d'être très moyen et trois
semaines après de très bons donc il
faudrait qu'on arrive à trouver un peu
un peu plus de régularité au niveau des
voitures
je passe confirme on finira même très
bien ces zones
mathieu je reste persuadé depuis qu'il a
obtenu sa majorité la vie de senna bien
changé c'est désormais l'indépendance
il a une voiture et son propre
appartement mais la déménager à promet
sur le plan professionnel sénat a obtenu
deux bonnes nouvelles
il a récupéré sa naissance et va donc
pouvoir rejouer en match officiel mais
surtout le club lui a fait signer son
premier contrat pro le premier juge et
rentre dans le vestiaire je vous adore à
ma droite je vois djibril cissé à ma
gauche montmagny en gt hôpital ya de
cela 5 6h ils voient à la télé tu ouvres
j'ai dû savais que j'avais peur au début
j'avais peur mais pour le dimanche
j'avais peur tout se refinancer des
stars et tout ça avec eux avec le projet
bouchra paix en quoi j'ai franchi un
palier senna peut enfin reprendre sa
carrière en main pendant la trêve il a
été appelé par didier deschamps avec
alexander et jordan pour participer au
stage d'entraînement de l'équipe une la
coupe d'afrique des nations privant l'om
de quelques joueurs
les jeunes sont sollicités l'occasion
pour eux de se faire une place chez
leurs aînés ça y est cette année
alexander aurait pu jouer avec l'équipe
nationale du gabon monsieur giresse m'a
appelé personnellement j'ai je vais
donner mon accord en fait et après mon
père il ya il avait appris ça ce pas que
l'était pas d'accord parce que lui aussi
il veut du jour pour le pays et
infantile et fernande gabonais il veut
que je joue pour les pays mais il m'a
dit que si je venais au gabon que tous
les caméras tous les photographes soit
sera un braqués sur moi en fait parce
que font se dresser à nouveau un doom
rookie qui joue un clip qui centrait et
les pros à l'om et on veut savoir ce
qu'il donne et il m'a dit oui et me
sentais pas capable de pouvoir porter
tout ça sur mes épaules en fait comme
pour nico sénat et jordan c'est une
situation paradoxale susceptibles de
rejoindre l'équipe nationale de leur
pays alors qu'ici il peine à intégrer
l'élite du club
ce soir pour le quart de finale de la
coupe de la ligue
alexander et jordan sont sur la feuille
de match depuis son but contre lorient
jordan n'a plus rejoué avec l'équipe
première
alexander lui n'a fait qu'une seule
apparition en coupe de france
difficile de se faire une place parmi
les grands joueurs dépensent 3 bien
parce qu'on avec les pros geass bon
choix avec les proches paris termes
nominaux c'est là qu'il faut travailler
ça qu'il faut tout donner
faut plus se poser de question et si
dire lui le plus fort comment je peux
pas rêver non il faut tout donner après
faut essayer de s'imposer parce qu'on
joue le haut niveau parce qu'il ya un
contexte une pression donc évidemment
oui il faut être très solide soit au
niveau footballistique mais aussi d'un
dans la tête dont les exigences se sont
beaucoup plus élevés que dans un club où
il ya moins de pression et ils peuvent
jouer peut-être plus tôt aussi donc oui
je sais c'est une évidence que c'est
plus difficile à marseille
face à une telle pression l'amitié est
un élément essentiel pour ne pas craquer
surtout pour ces jeunes expatriés
alexander et jordan sont amis depuis
leur arrivée au centre de formation à
l'âge de 13 ans les deux compères se
soutiennent mutuellement partagent
ensemble l'éloignement de la famille des
doutes mais aussi les espoirs c'est
franchement c'est pour moi c'est un
frère en fait même plus un pote c'est un
fera pas ce que dit tout et on s'entend
parfaitement bien sur le terrain aussi
quand on joue ensemble on three carlos
ferreira essaie de se régaler le maximum
de ce fait le maximum de passe et après
la fin du match on en parle ensemble à
bord après jour leur faudra mêmes partir
mais si pardon puis par un barcelone ce
que je souhaite le plus ou dans un grand
club ça me gardera toujours un coin de
taille parce que c'est des choses qu'on
n'oublie pas comme ça dans la vie si
c'est ça reste gravé pour toujours
malheureusement alexander et jordan
n'entreront pas sur le terrain ce soir
mais l'om se qualifie pour les demi
finales de la coupe de la ligue
l'apprentissage du métier se fait aussi
en dehors du terrain maintenant qu'ils
ont un pied chez les pros ces jeunes
doivent être en mesure de faire face aux
médias
le club a donc mis en place des cours de
media training afin de les préparer à
répondre aux journalistes
tu peux faire les deux si tu sens que tu
est perturbé par des questions sur la
caméra
si tu veux faire passer un message fort
tu regarde la caméra si tu veux montrer
justement que mes questions et également
que tu me regardes à moi et tu me le
fait qu'on prend ok apprend viser
l'europe ça tranquillement c'est bon
allez tiens à marquer face à lorient en
championnat
justement est ce que j'espère faire
partie de ce groupe face à valenciennes
franchement si on fait appel à moi je
serai je vais tout donner comme j'ai
fait à lorient
si on fait appel à moi que je dois les
jo-1912 du tout faire pour tout donner
en cfa 2 j'espérais turnover de didier
deschamps que concernant et pouvant être
dans le groupe pour toulouse comment
j'espère un terme aux hommes de didier
deschamps concernant et pour être dans
le groupe pour tous ces mots tu dis sur
le bouton fait que style
le soir on en revient au maire il
s'informe de respect aux civils a mis
des gens qui te gêne en rien est encore
une fois ce n'est pas n'importe qui si
les jantes interview tu passes à la télé
tu représentes les choses pour les
jeunes
encore là des chefs vous pensez que ça
peut être à la fraude d'un stade le
préparateur physique ou la coach sait
c'est la faute à tout le monde c'est la
faute à tout ça paie toi est-ce que tu
comprends derrière le sujet moi je
diffuse le sujet d'accord c'est tout éco
par endroits l'entraîneur va le voir
imagine les conséquences derrière
imagine toi pour la suite de ta carrière
imagine la relation tu vas voir avec
l'entraîneur et le staff
est-ce que tu comprends les conséquences
qu'il peut avoir pour une seule phrase
une seule phrase ça peut avoir de graves
conséquences pour la suite même déjà
votre jeune âge et ça c'est important ça
ça c'est important
tandis que l'om enchaîne les victoires
sa petite soeur a du mal à rester
régulière désormais il faudrait finir le
championnat sans aucune défaite pour
espérer monter en cfa autant dire que
l'espoir s'éloigne de plus en plus cette
année avec la cfa bon on souffre moi
d'être championne cf avec un groupe
solide et est un joueur capable de
jeunes pros ça m'intéresse est pas moi
je peux faire souffrir finir tout 13e et
à la fin de la nuit d'hier était il ya
deux trois joueurs qui méritent de
passer pro là on a fait notre travail
ce week end ils reçoivent nîmes
un match qui si après deux ans d'absence
le retour d'olivier heureux de
rechausser les crampons
la reprise dans le groupe donc voilà
enfin sa part est arrivé est arrivé une
reprise voit ça va je suis content
surtout que j'ai repris j'ai bien
compris je me sens bien
son cloclo douleur donc donc voilà je me
sens prêt à reprendre et et puis bon je
suis heureux et on autant j'attends d'y
être parce que toutes les péripéties qui
sont arrivées chaque fois je devais
jouer je me suis blessé juste avant donc
j'attends vraiment le dernier moment
d'être sur le terrain pour pouvoir
savourer cette reprise la faune et la
flore et demi 13h45 d'investir pas ici
une chose 13h45 tout régler
bon
alors que l'om s'est qualifié pour la
finale de la coupe de la ligue
la tension monte au sein de l'équipe
réserve désormais elle n'a plus le droit
à l'erreur il faut à présent que cette
jeune formation trouve une cohérence il
faut travailler faut que tu avais voulu
tenir là
mais seules recettes kelis et ceux de
che savoir se remettre en question faire
une bonne analyse sur votre question
depuis qu'une chine a travaillé pendant
six ans
alexander jordan et senna doivent quant
à eux prouvé qu'ils méritent d'être les
espoirs de l'om aujourd'hui le staff pro
est venu les voir jouer
une raison de plus pour faire la
différence olivier doit dépasser son
angoisse de la blessure et retrouver son
meilleur niveau
mais ironie du sort alors qu'il fait sa
réapparition sur le terrain nikos est
quant à lui grièvement blessé à
l'entraînement on attend le verdict des
analyses médicales à la mi temps c'est
nîmes qui mène 1 0
par contre le mettre au sol revue les
bassins
au fond je ressens comme ça j'ai ça
commente péter mais faire du mal aux
abonnés avec le bateau
coc
des shows pour y aller
la lisière